what are you trying to accomplish  that's the question because we have to  accomplish happiness that has to be the  goal and if you actually pressured  yourself to be happy versus pressuring  yourself to be a success then you have a  totally different conversation with  yourself and when you start doing that  for yourself not to prove it to your  spouse or your siblings or your parents  or the people you went to school with  then it gets really good it gets really  good when it gets really quiet and it's  super quiet for me i don't hear the  claps and i don't hear the boos i just  navigate i love my process i love the  pain of being an entrepreneur i love  that it's lonely i love the game i just  want you to love the game